new reports of friction between
president biden and vp harris the latest
claims from a new book detailing how
harris felt disrespected when white
house aides would not stand for her as
she entered a room like they normally
would for biden and the vice president
was reportedly furious over the photo
that vogue used when she was featured on
the cover wearing converse sneakers but
biden's team told her to back down
because it was quote a first world
problem
we don't have a ton of time so i'm going
to lead with the example i care about
most which is the vogue cover
and
i agree with her on this i don't know
dana what you think i i don't here's the
thing
she she posed for the photograph in the
outfit
right and now i know that they were they
were told oh yeah we'll probably use the
other one whatever they maybe they
thought they had assurances but when you
go you don't control the editorial of a
photo shoot you don't so if you don't
want to be film you just want to
photograph wearing your sneakers on the
front page of vogue don't wear them
don't ever do it and that you could
blame her staff if she wants to blame
somebody else don't blame anna wintour
whatever she should blame her staff if
you want to look a certain way you have
to dress a certain way the other thing
is i don't i was trying to remember i
don't believe that you stand for the
vice president when he enters the room i
know i don't i love dick cheney i don't
believe we ever did if he was if it's
just him if the president's coming in
with him yes you do but no i don't think
so
judge couldn't agree more if you don't
want to be photographed in converse and
that pantsuit don't put them on for the
shoot don't pose for the shoot tell them
i'm not wearing this i've done that
before just say no i'm not wearing this
okay and nobody needs to stand up for
you you're not that important that's
enough well she's kind of important
she's like second well no but nobody in
the white house is standing up for her
she's upset that they're not i'm pretty
sure they didn't stand for joe biden
when he was vice president
right would you stand no offense jessica
but this is when i wish geraldo was here
because at this point he would go
when i was on the cover of playgirls and
then they showed
i was shirtless
and i wore these leather chaps i didn't
want to wear the leather chaps but i
wore them anyway but i didn't complain
because it was a decision i made with
the leather chaps
well good news for geraldo back next
week
you can feature this story again or he
could go topless uh
jesse thank you for putting geraldo and
leather chat to my brain
yeah no but he's right you know you
don't go nude for a photo shoot if you
don't want your whole naked body on the
cover of vogue or play girl yeah and
anna wintour's usually right isn't she
always right about everything so you
don't argue with adam my favorite thing
about this i don't argue with anna the
vp staff floated the idea of maybe
starting to oversee relations with the
nordic countries yeah
maybe some low-risk
nordic countries instead of the nordic
the northern triangle she wanted to go
to oslo and copenhagen they had to start
off slow down the show started with
nordic track what was what were there
issues that she was wanting to deal with
i don't understand that yeah yeah and
apparently the white house laughed at
that yeah um
okay
i still think that that photo should not
have been on the cover and it could have
been embedded in the chute
is i would have owned it it would be
like i look good in conversation well
she died cool but that's why it's
self-complaining
all right own it she's on vogue come on
okay melania trump one more thing is up
next exactly hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else